we recently took a look at razors latest
14 inch gaming laptop the new blade
which we appreciated for its sturdy
design and solid performance we also
fell in love with its high res screen a
qhd+ panel with a native resolution of
3200 by 1800 but despite looking great
its admittedly over the top in a major
contributor to the increase in price
over the previous 14 inch blade razors
17 inch blade Pro is also back for 2014
and while it hasn't been tweaked as much
as its smaller cousin it's definitely an
improvement over the last year at a
glance the new blade pro mirrors the
physical design of last year's model
sharing the same dimensions and ports
with the only difference being that it's
0.04 pounds lighter the thin aluminum
chassis feels great and for a 17-inch
gaming laptop the blade pro is as thin
and light as it currently guess though
it's great to see that some things never
change
including the blades fantastic keyboard
the switchblade UI trackpad is a feature
that's needed refining since its
inception and unfortunately nothing's
changed since last year
the promise of the switchblade UI a
full-color touchscreen display with 10
customizable keys with displays of their
own isn't as enticing as it's made out
to be with the secondary display you can
run apps alongside or in unison with
desktop apps and with the customizable
keys you can define hotkeys for various
applications and implement full-color
icons to give them character sure enough
these features work but the problem is
the compromises that arise from their
inclusion especially the touchscreen the
issues with the Switchblade UI go beyond
its distinct features for one the
plastic surface that protects the
display is a poor surface for a laptop
trackpad but simply the surface tension
is easily disrupted by even the
slightest amount of residue resulting in
an input that feels inconsistent it's
positioned to the right of the keyboard
which is unusual for a laptop and will
take some getting used to on the plus
side it makes sense from a comfort
standpoint if you can't use a mouse when
gaming on the go the 10 customizable
keys are functionally better than the
trackpad but despite razors marketing
images the perky displays are recessed
into the keys
rather than positioned on the top and
the lensing effect that's used to direct
the image towards the left done for
visibility makes things a blurry mess
from any other angle personally I found
no worth in the ability to run apps on
my keyboard if I'm playing a game I'm
focused on the action on screen and if I
have the time to shift my attention away
from the game
focused on the Switchblade screen and I
could just as easily alt-tab into
another window on my actual monitor the
new pro model also comes with the same
CPU as last year and intel core i7 4708
q quad-core CPU at 2.4 gigahertz but
it's paired with a new GPU Nvidia is
860m in addition to 16 gigabytes of ddr3
RAM which is twice as much as the
previous model the 860m represents a
significant jump in performance over
last year's 765 in but it's not as
strong as the 870 in the 14 inch blade
in terms of hardware the blade pros
advantage is that it has a slightly
faster CPU and twice as much RAM but
when it comes to in-game performance the
14 inch blade is the stronger contender
the blade Pro does benefit from slightly
better battery life lasting around 90
minutes during extreme gaming scenarios
and close to five hours while web
browsing word processing and media
streaming sessions the 1080p LCD panel
on the blade pro is neither impressive
nor disappointing given its size and the
money spent on other features it's a tad
unfortunate that it maxes out at 1920 by
1080 but it doesn't stand out in
practice only when you're weighing the
merits of the screen relative to the
rest of the laptops premium features in
terms of inputs the blade pro has the
essentials cover three USB 3.0 ports
Ethernet headphone and microphone combo
port and HDMI out it's worth noting that
it lacks an SD card slot which is
quickly becoming commonplace in the
laptop market considering that razer
sells this laptop for a minimum of 2,300
dollars for the 128 gigabyte model it's
a shame that it hasn't kept up with
industry standards if you need more
storage prepared to spend $2,500 for the
256 gigabyte version or $2,800 for the
512 gigabyte model given that high cost
it's also disappointing that you'll have
to settle for medium to high graphics
settings very high or ultra settings are
simply out of reach if you want playable
framerates
running the same benchmarks as the blade
it's clear that the pro model is the
weakest of the two even though it's the
most expensive recommending the blade
pro in a world where the new blade
offers better performance with less
money is difficult the extra RAM and
faster CPU look good on paper but the
results speak for themselves
unless you need a 17 inch display you're
better off in almost every respect by
choosing the 14 inch blade if you want
one of razor's thin and light gaming
laptops it's better at gaming it
features a remarkable screen it's more
portable and it isn't plagued by a
trackpad that's occasionally
inconsistent